let's say I go to a store and I have $50
in my pocket $50 in my wallet and at the
store that day they say it is a 25% off
marked price sale so 25% off mark price
means that if the marked price is $100
the price I'm going to pay is going to
be 25% less than $100 so my question to
you is if I have $50 what is the highest
marked price I can afford because I need
to know that before I go finding
something that I that I might like so
let's do a little bit of algebra so let
X X be the highest marked price that I
can afford so if the sale is 25% off of
X we could say that the new price the
sale price will be X minus 25% 25% of X
is equal to the sale price and I'm
assuming that I'm in a state without
sales tax
whatever the sale price is is what I
have to pay cash
so X minus 25% X is equal to sale price
right the discount is going to be 25% of
X well we know that this is the same
thing as X minus 0.25 X and we know that
that's the same thing as well because we
know this is 1 X X is the same thing as
1 X 1 X minus 0.25 X well this that
means that 0.75 X is equal to the sale
price right all I did is I rewrote X
minus 25% of X as 1 X minus 0.25 X and
that's the same thing as 0.75 X right
because 1 minus 0.25 is points
five so 0.75 X is going to be the sale
price well what's the sale price that I
can afford
well the sale price I can afford is $50
so 0.75 X is going to equal $50 anything
if X is any larger number than the
number I'm solving for then the sale
price is going to be more than $50 and I
won't be able to afford it so that's how
we set the exam the the highest I can
pay is 50 and that's the sale price so
going back to how we did these problems
before we just divide both sides by 0.75
and we say that the highest sales the
highest marked price that I can afford
is 50 divided by 0.75 and let's figure
out what that is 0.75 goes into 50 let's
add some 0s on the back if I take this
decimal move it two to the right take
this decimal move it two to the right
goes right there so point seven five
goes into 50 the same number of times
that 75 goes into five thousand so let's
do this seventy five goes into 50 zero
times seventy five goes into 500 so let
me think about that I think it goes into
it six times because right because seven
times going to be too much so let's go
ahead go into it six times six times
five is thirty six times seven is 42
plus three is 45 so the remainder is 50
I see a pattern
bring down the zero well same thing
again 75 goes into 500 six times six
times seventy five is going to be 450
again and we're going to keep having
that same pattern over and over and over
again so it's actually 666 point six six
six I hope you don't think I'm an evil
person because of this number that
happened to show up but anyway so the
highest sale price that I can afford or
the highest marked price I can afford is
$66
and if I were to round up and
sixty-seven cents vote around to the
nearest penny if I were to write this
kind of as a repeating decimal I could
write this as sixty six point six six
repeating or I also know that point six
six six six going on forever is the same
thing as two thirds of 66 and two-thirds
but since we're working with money and
working at dollars we should just round
to the nearest penny so the highest
marked price that I can afford is sixty
six dollars and 67 cents so if I go and
I see a nice pair of shoes for $55 I can
afford it if I see a pair of if I see a
nice tie for $70 I can't afford it with
the fifty dollars in my pocket
so hopefully this this uh not only will
just teach a little bit of math but
it'll it'll help you do a little bit of
shopping so let me ask you another
problem a very interesting problem let's
say I start with an arbitrary well let's
let's put a fixed number on let's say I
start with $100 and after one year one
year it grows by grows by 25% and then
the next year year two let's call that
year two it shrinks by 25% so this could
have happened in the stock market the
first year I have a good year my
portfolio grows by 25% the second you
have a bad year in the my portfolio
shrinks by 25% so my question is how
much money do I have at the end of the
two years well a lot of people might say
oh this is easy sell if I grow by 25% of
then I shrink by 25% I'll end up with
the same amount of money but I'll show
you it's actually not that simple
because the 25% in either case or in
both cases as I was actually a different
amount of money so let's figure this out
if I start with $100 and I grow it by
25% 25% of 100 is $25 so I grew it by
$25 so I go to 125 dollars right so
after one year of growing by 25% I end
up with 125 dollars
and now this $125 is going to shrink by
25% so if something shrinks by 25% that
means it's just going to be 0.75 or 75%
of what it was before right 1 minus 25
percent 75 0.75 times 125 so let's work
that out here 125 times 0.75 and it's in
case you're confused if something I just
I don't want to repeat it too much but
if something shrinks by 25% it is now
75% of its original value so if 125
shrinks by 25% it's now 75% of 125 or
0.75 do the math 5 times 5 is 25 2 times
5 is 10 plus 2 is 12 1 times 5 7 ok 7
times 5 is 35 7 times 2 is 14 plus 3 is
17 sorry
7 times 1 is 7 plus 1 is 8 so it's 5/7
and then this is a 7 actually 14 9 94.7
five right two decimal points two
decimal points 94.7 5 so it's
interesting
if I start with $100 and it grows by 25%
and then it shrinks by 25% I end up with
less than I started with and I want you
to think about why that happens because
25% on a hundred is the amount that I'm
gaining that's a smaller number than the
amount that I'm losing I'm losing 25% on
a hundred and twenty-five that's pretty
interesting what you think and that's
actually very interesting when a lot of
people compare well actually I won't go
into stock returns and things but I
think that should be a pretty
interesting thing you should try that
out with other examples another
interesting thing is for any percentage
gain you should think about how much you
would have to lose what percentage you
would have to lose to end up where you
started
another interesting project to figure
out maybe I'll do that in a in a future
presentation but anyway I think you're
now ready to do some of that those
percent madness problems hope hope you
have fun bye